let me tell you there's nothing more  rock and roll than taking out the bad  guys for the red white and blue  panama's about to explode  welcome to the jungle  this is where i come in to clean it up  [Music]  last time you were in the fields a long  time ago i'm rusty  make sure you hit him in the head  i was talking to myself  oh make sure you break his neck  if there's ever a guy needed for a tough  job  this was him  he might go  there are some friends of uncle sam  looking for creative ways to fund  contrast the first order of business buy  chopper  monsters want the chopper and return  they'll give us weaponry and insects one  question  sure  talk about a helicopter shall we later  panama has lots to offer a man like you  i'm alive  and anyone close to him  [Music]  it seems killing senor becker just makes  him more angry  nice  [Music]  you